The mathematics of
the correlation
coefficient are important.
But it is perhaps more important
to be able to
interpret it correctly.
A correlation coefficient of
let's say 0.5, tells us that
something interesting is going
on as far as the relation of X
and Y is concerned.
But what exactly?
It tells us that the two
random variables are
associated in some sense.
But this is often misinterpreted
to mean that
there is a causal relation
between the two.
But this is wrong.
A large correlation coefficient
in general does
not indicate that there is a
causal relation between the
random variables.
As an example, suppose that
X somehow quantifies the
mathematical aptitude
of a person.
And Y somehow quantifies the
musical ability of a person.
In general, it has been found
that mathematical aptitude and
musical ability are
correlated.
People who score high on
one will score high on
the other as well.
Is there a causal relation?
If you study math a lot and you
become very good at math,
does it mean that you would
become a better musician?
Not necessarily.
Or if you practice the violin
day in and day out, does it
mean that you will score better
in the math exam?
Again, not necessarily.
Perhaps what is going on is that
there's a certain feature
of the human brain and when
that feature is well
developed, then that feature
helps both in math and in
musical ability.
And this is a typical situation
of how a correlation
coefficient may arise.
That is often a correlation
coefficient that's
significant, reflects that there
is an underlying common
but perhaps hidden factor that
affects both of the random
variables X and Y.
Let's us go through a simple
numerical example that models
a situation of this kind.
Suppose that Z, V, and w are
independent random variables.
And that we have two more random
variables defined by
these relations.
Not that there's no direct
influence from X to Y or from
Y to X.
But on the other hand, there's
a common underlying factor,
this random variable Z that
affects both X and Y. Because
of this, we expect that X and Y
will somehow have some kind
of relation or association
between them.
And we would like to measure
the strength of that
association.
The way to measure it will be
in terms of the correlation
coefficient, which we will
now proceed to compute.
To have a complete example in
our hands and in order to also
keep things simple, let's
us assume that the basic
underlying random variable Z, V,
and W all have 0 means and
unit variances.
And now let us take the
definition of the correlation
coefficient and start
calculating.
Let us look at the variance of
X. Because X is the sum of two
independent random variables,
its variance is going to be
the sum of those variances.
And we have assumed that each
one of those variances is
equal to 1.
So the variance of
X is equal to 2.
And that implies that the
standard deviation of X is
equal to the square root of 2.
By a similar argument, the
standard deviation of Y is
also equal to the square
root of 2.
Now, let us look at the
covariance between X and Y.
Because X and Y have 0 means,
the covariance is just the
expected value of the product
of the two random variables.
And using the definition of
what these two random
variables are, it's this
particular product here.
We expand the product into
a sum of four terms.
And take the expected value of
each one of the four terms.
Which leaves us with this
particular expression here.
Now, Z has 0 mean and
unit variance.
Therefore, the expected value
of Z squared is equal to 1.
How about the next term?
V and Z are independent.
So the expected value of the
product is the product of the
expected values.
But the expected values are
zero, so this term is zero.
And with a similar argument,
the other
terms are zero as well.
So the co-variance
is equal to 1.
And from this, we can conclude
our calculation and write that
the correlation coefficient
between X and Y is equal to 1
divided by the square root of
2 times square root of 2,
which is 1/2.
This example also serves to give
you a rough idea of what
it may mean to have
a correlation
coefficient of 1/2.
It means that the two
random variables
have some common elements.
And they also have some
idiosyncratic elements.
And these two elements are
roughly equal in weight.
If V and W were completely
absent, the correlation
coefficient would have been 1.
If on the other hand V and W had
a huge variance, so as to
completely hide the effect of
Z, then the value of the
correlation coefficient would
have been much, much smaller
perhaps closer to 0.
And in the extreme case of
course where Z is completely
absent, then X and Y are
independent, and we get a
correlation coefficient of 0.